- Okay you don't like the
mention of-
- dead people hair, fine.
Er we'll look at that.
Is there
anything else?
- Yeah, that song.
Is that you two singing?
[both laugh]
- Guilty as charged.
- Yeah, it is. It is.
- Oh, okay, okay.
When are you gonna bring in
the real singers?
- I'm sorry, did you say
real singers?
- Yeah, real singers.
- [laughs]
- Wow.
- I mean--
- I mean, like, real singers?
- I mean,
I'm right here.
I'm listening.
I'm going, "What the [bleep]?"
- WTF?
- I mean, she's like,
"Real singers,"
to my face, to your face.
- Dumb to my face,
you know what I mean?
- There is to be absolutely
no mention of dead people.
I just want a sexy lady
on a sexy horse
and a nice, sexy song...
- I mean, that's basically
what you got.
- Not sung by you two.
- [groans]